in fact last year Jill my wife traveled
with Deb to the Cherokee Immersion
School in Oklahoma
the Cherokee Nation used part of this
funding to start building a second
school and Revitalize the use of the
Cherokee language
by the way she spent a lot of time on
other reservations other nations as well
I'm worried she's not going to come home
one of these days when she goes
you think I'm joking I'm telling you if
I hear more about the navajos than I
hear about me
[Music]
um
you all think I'm kidding
no we don't think you're kidding all
right now meanwhile in Washington Biden
is calling on Congress to pass
legislation to avert a major rail strike
that would further [ __ ] the economy
now the house earlier today passed a
bill to force the rail workers back to
work but it is still facing major
hurdles in the U.S Senate all right
joining us now Economist Steve Moore Fox
News contributor Charlie hurt so Steve
we've gone over these numbers the Biden
inflation is costing the average
household 7 200 a year uh we're going
back to record high gas prices we'll
have record heating prices this winter
he says he's not going to change a thing
and he is adhering to this policy of no
domestic energy production but he's
willing to go to a murdering dictator
Thug Maduro in Venezuela and make that
country rich and it's not even a leader
that this country recognizes as a
legitimate leader can you explain that
to me no I can't explain it help me out
here I don't think anybody could explain
the logic of this one I mean look we
have more oil gas and coal than any
other country in the world under Donald
Trump uh as he used to talk about we we
created Saudi America we were don't
forget when he left office Sean the
United States was the top producer of
energy in the world we didn't have to
worry about OPEC we didn't have to worry
about Saudi Arabia or Russia or
countries like Venezuela now you've got
a president who just what was it a
couple of weeks ago said uh we're gonna
we're gonna stop the drilling in America
uh and yet then two weeks later Sean he
says oh but we are going
Drilling in Venezuela so let me get this
straight we're going to get our oil and
gas and coal from China from Russia from
Venezuela from Iran but we can't get it
from Texas we can't get it from North
Dakota Alaska West Virginia no I can't
explain that it's it's not putting
America First As Trump did it's is
putting America last can you explain
Charlie hurt I thought the Railroad
Strike had been averted because of Joe's
involvement and now we're back to it and
now he's asking Congress to fix it but
he was claiming that he was the most
pro-union president ever uh how do you
reconcile that
yeah no it's a giant lie and of course
the only reason we're talking about it
right now is because the media was all
too happy to cover up the fact that uh
that that Joe Biden had done nothing to
resolve the situation with the rail
workers before the election but they
just had to keep it under wraps long
enough to get us through the election
now that the election is over suddenly
the media is willing to uh you know
State and talk about the obvious which
is we still have a pending strike and
you have the the occupant of the White
House who says who now claims to be the
the most pro-worker pro-union president
we've ever had and yet he is getting
ready to force these workers to go back
to work and you know I'm not disputing
whether you know what's the right
approach here but he can't have it both
ways the way the media is all too happy
to to allow him but you know the one
thing I got to give him credit for he is
he is correct no president has done more
than than Joe Biden is is done in the
first two years of his administration he
opened our Southern border he destroyed
our energy Independence he doubled the
price of gasoline in this country he uh
had a disastrous withdrawal from
Afghanistan he allowed Vladimir Putin to
invade Ukraine and uh and and he's
ushered in you know uh you know eight
eight percent uh uh inflation and so uh
yeah you know maybe he said the one true
thing nobody has done anything like this
in history
let me ask Steve if you look at the deal
that's on the table for the rail workers
they're going to get a 24 pay increase
and on average uh most workers will get
about an 11 000 bonus that doesn't sound
like a horrible deal to me
well this is a fiasco I mean this is a
total Fiasco an egg on the face of this
White House this has been uh we've known
about this issue for six months that
this strike might occur and we can't
have our rail workers going on strike it
would cause you know all sorts of
problems for the American economy and
yet remember two or three weeks before
the election I don't know if you
remember this Sean the president had a
press conference at in the Rose Garden
at the White House declaring Victory on
this I've solved the problem mission
accomplished he took a Victory lap of
course it was only to punt the thing
past the election then we could pass the
election he can't solve the problem and
now he's punning putting it to Congress
Sean that's not presidential leadership
that's not a what a president does Okay
the reason these the reason these
workers are so angry frankly is when
you've got eight you've had 15 inflation
since Biden came into office so workers
are agitated because their paychecks are
shrinking Sean
well Charlie what happens if we get a
situation where they pass a law and they
rail workers decide not to go back to
work will they do what Ronald Reagan did
with the air traffic controls will they
fire them will Joe Biden fire the union
workers and what would that do to the
Democratic party's relationship with
unions
that's a great question
um you know on the on the face of it I
would say that I don't think the Joe
Biden would do anything that's going to
put America first so that's the first
question but would he do anything to
protect his power to protect Democrats
in Congress yeah I think that he would
do anything and you know the other thing
that I think is important to remember
with these rail workers is if these rail
workers who make over a hundred thousand
on average over a hundred thousand
dollars a year are in such pain because
of this inflation that they're talking
about doing a lockout and and shutting
down our Railways imagine what all the
other workers who in this country many
most of whom make below a hundred
thousand dollars a year imagine how much
Agony they're in right now and they the
only difference is they don't have the
power to get the attention but at the
end of the day though probably we the
taxpayers will kick in every time
someone gets on air what do you call it
Amtrak we we pay for that that service
in part anyway thank you both hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else